the Lord is with me
I would not be afraid
what can a mere man do to me
the doors kitchen overseers storm inside
sees Peter who violently resists said
now boy
Sybian moves him to help
Betsy cries
sheer chaos
this was without question the hardest
film of my my entire career
I live in doubt from the moment I say
yes to a character until a Magic Moment
there's a magic moment of comprehension
and you never know when that magic
moment
is going to show up
Barefoot okay that'll be fine that'll
work okay
I think it's gonna be easier for
whoever's putting it on and how does
that feel
[Music]
yeah but we're hoping that that will
always go over the uh
[Music]
um
whoa
[Music]
it turns off your
agency you don't want to step you don't
want to move
you don't want to look anybody in the
face it's deeply dehumanizing
it's
like
in the most basic simple textures of
human interaction you just you turn it
off
just turn it off you know it's uh
it's gonna be a long hard summer
[Music]
hair is I think is Paramount and
essential to the character I'm hoping to
create a man who is strong a man who has
integrity and a man who has had a very
rough life to say the least
the shape has to be flattering but it
has to tell a story that he's never seen
any vanity before he doesn't know vanity
Pierce Austin like hair stylist did such
a brilliant job it's like nobody notices
that that's a wig It's A Wig that
disappears in the mind of the audience
but it's so critical in delivering the
character and you know touching that
space inside of the audience how his
hair looks is so critical yet it
disappears
foreign
makeup and wardrobe is always
one of the first thresholds for me to
fall into character
you know once I see myself in the mirror
it transforms your thoughts and feelings
it changes how you walk changes how to
hold my mouth the makeup definitely
intensifies whatever Peter is
experiencing that day and I have to keep
that in mind every day Peter coming into
the construction camps the first time he
arrives to this uh slave encampment
where he's been abducted from his family
all right let's clear the set please
let's stand by picture we'll be next
that Confederate War Camp is one of the
best designed and most accurate sets
I've ever been on
[Music]
all of the sounds
[Music]
the life of the camp got created you can
feel the pain you can feel the suffering
it's like the walls are talking to you
it made it that much more difficult to
emotionally depict but as an actor it
was spectacular to be surrounded and
immersed in that way
for the fin shell on the outside what's
the color
how do they feel
bad yeah they're always out with uh
dialect anywhere so
I see you how you doing you want to hear
the dialogue yeah there is that many
others steadier so long day out here
studious
maybe you said
that steady accept
long day out here the dialect is a major
part of the storytelling
this is just work
same as you always done Peter's dialect
is Haitian Creole just prior to the
Haitian revolution the slave owners were
escaping and they were coming to America
a huge Haitian contingent came into that
Louisiana area so Haitian French was the
best guesstimate of what Peter probably
spoke
I do not know why
God shows himself to some people
and not to others
but if you do not know him
I will pray for you
Peter's spirituality was one of the most
interesting Explorations for me to
understand how someone can survive this
level of brutality this level of
suffering and it came down to Peter's
faith
you learn all your lines you learn your
dialect you get your hair and you get
your makeup you you know you rehearse
with some of the other actors you do all
of those things but what could give a
person the fortitude and the endurance
to be able to sustain with that level of
violence and and malevolence and you
know God was the only answer
[Music]
there's a magical moment
when you understand a character in a
non-intellectual way there was an
interesting thing at Peter's writings
where he had been beaten into a coma and
he had been unconscious for months and
when he comes out he talks about having
met God he heard and cultivated a
relationship with God he felt like he
knew God so he had gone beyond faith
into a place that few of us get to visit
[Music]
I just I love working to understand the
mindset of that that kind of character
it's not a movie about slavery
it's a movie about freedom
and the power of faith
combined with love
being invincible